I remember one time I had a woman come
in and she came in and she had perfect
credit she had like 750 credit scores I
mean it was perfect and she came in and
uh one of the Brokers came in and said
hey man he's can I show you something I
was like yeah what's up he he was look
he said I've got this This Woman's W2s
here I said okay I looked at him and he
goes here's your credit report and he
goes here's the you know application
this is the this is the social security
number I went all right and he said this
is the social security number on the W2
and I went okay keep in mind you go to
get a car loan or credit card they never
ask for these things so and he was like
and I'm really shocked he even noticed
it I probably might not have even caught
it but he they were different and I went
really and he goes yeah he said um so I
I did you know she just brought them in
you know she's here I was like oh bring
her in here so she came in sat down and
said listen here's what we just found
and she was likeoh okay you know what I
don't want the loan I I just I go no no
no no I said listen you're getting the
loan you got a 750 credit score like I
don't care what we have to do we're
getting you the loan I just want to know
what's going on how are how did you we
how did you get 750 credit scores under
this social security number when clearly
this is your real social security number
you've been working for this company for
10 years and your credit profile says
it's only like three years old MH and I
was like what happened and what she told
me she did was she had been she went
through a divorce she had been married
for 10 years used her husband's I mean
his surname for 10 years so she she has
no credit under her maiden name MH but
when they got divorced she switched to
her maiden
name um because when she pulled tried to
get anything in her in her um husband's
surname it was denied bad credit so he
had bad credit their credit went bad so
he switched to her she switched to her
name and a friend told her if she needed
to get her electric or anything turned
on she could use her name and use her
daughter's or son's social security
number which was like a four-year-old
kid y so she used that and it went
through she had to put a deposit down
but it went through at least wasn't
denied so that went through then she
went and she applied for an apartment
with
that sure enough it went through she had
no credit but they saidou don't have bad
credit so she said once she moved into
the apartment she then started getting
these pre-approved credit cards so she
she goes but I knew I had applied there
using my son's social security number
let's say so she started filling those
out and sure enough she got a credit
card and then she got two and then she
got a pre-approval from Ford Motor
Credit she went and got herself a new
car got approved she'd been making the
payments ever since she has 750 credit
scores she thought she'd try her hand at
buying a house in his name in his social
security number and
we caught it and she got a house in that
name we we closed it I just was like wow
like this is great can I ask you a
question about that because it seems
like she's able to pay for everything
right so while this is highly
elegal is it unethical is it
like it's it's unethical in that it's
messing with the system on which a lot
of people
rely but it feels like there's some
aspect of the system that's broken in
that it doesn't give people like her a
second chance she could have claimed
bankruptcy and then two years later
listen two years out of bankruptcy you
can go into Bank of America and get a
conventional mortgage assuming you have
perfect credit outside the bankruptcy
you have the down payment you make
enough money there's a whole bunch of
you know a bunch of uh underwriting
guidelines you have to meet but that's
possible but you're right for instance
she wasn't getting an apartment using
with her bad credit she wasn't getting
her utilities turned on she was wasn't
getting any of those things done so
getting your life back on track is just
harder it's extremely hard so there's a
temptation to take the shortcut and the
shortcut is often going to be illegal
right and she stumbled into it but she
basically explained it to me and I I
mean I don't think she had walked out of
the of my brokerage office before I went
and I just started making up you know
names and I think I went I went and into
our file cabinet and grabbed some
people's uh 1040s which we had you
know their tax returns and looked up
children's Social Security numbers and
just grabbed some random kid Social
Security numbers and their name and went
and pulled them and sure and you know
but I changed their date of birth to be
an adult pulled it and sure enough it
came up no file found you know it didn't
say fraud alert or fraud or anything
didn't say mismatch this mismatch that
didn't say anything it just said you
know no file found well
then we went and we pulled applied for a
couple credit cards
using a child social security number and
then we went and pulled Our Own Credit
Report and sure enough it didn't say no
no file found it just said that there
had been two
inquiries applying for credit cards so I
was like wow like that's a credit
profile so that turns into
me going to Social
Security and calling or calling Social
Security and trying to get them to issue
me Social Security numbers to adults
that had never had a social security
number issued to them I need to get
Social Security number to give me a
clean social security number but I
called up and of course you know I'm a
novice I don't really know what I'm
doing so I call up and I say hey uh yeah
I was I'm uh never had a Social Security
Number issue and they were like how old
are you and I was like I'm 31 years old
you know and they were yeah that's not
possible do you have a driver's license
uh yeah you have a bank account yeah you
have a social security number uh bring
your driver's license in and we'll we'll
pull it up okay well that's not going to
happen hang up call back hi um my
son is seven years old or three years
old and he he had never had a social
security number issued oh okay was he
born in a hospital yes well he has one
he has one go ahead and uh get your son
come in here no I'm not doing that hang
up call back so I called back probably
times and
eventually uh someone said I I kept
altering it kept altering what I was
saying till I got to the point where I
was
saying my son was born with a midwife
not in the hospital and the pediatrician
told us that we needed to go we need to
get Social Security to issue a social
security number and they would say well
he should have issued it but that does
happen sometimes so bring your son in
and we'll you know you can fill out the
paperwork we'll have one issued you know
first we'll check to see he never had
one issued and if he hasn't we'll issue
one and so then it turned into my son is
out of the country and I need this and
then that turned into oh I'm sorry well
how old is he I was like um you know
he's three and they go well I'm sorry if
he's over the age of 12 months old he
has to come in hang up the phone call
back my son is is 10 months old he's out
of the country born with a midwife never
had a social security number and then
they go oh okay that's fine just get his
birth certificate and a shot his shot
record and you can come in fill out the
paperwork we'll get issue you a social
security number and that's what I did so
I figured out how to create a birth
certificate you know I ordered the
security paper you know when uh where
you make a copy it says you know void if
copied so I ordered had to order a bunch
of that and I went online and figured
out how to make a a fake birth
certificate it was great too cuz like
the county actually they give you a a
blank form and then they actually show
you what it looks like filled out like a
handwritten one filled out so I knew if
he was born this day he got these shots
um two months later he got these shot
six months later he got these shot so I
just filled it out I even had to order a
a seal so you have to have a seal that
says like he'll Boro County vital
statistics or Richland County vital
statistics or something and I couldn't
get anybody to make that so I changed it
to like Richland County Office of
virtual um records and then I took like
220 grit sandpaper and and and hit it
over and over and over again to wear it
down and then I State you know I did the
embossment on the on the corner and you
know I printed it on the security paper
embossed it nobody looks at those things
you could see Richland County you know
you you could kind of see that and
really they just grab it and they go
like this this is what you realize after
you when I started getting started
getting uh driver's licenses issued by
uh by the State DMV right the state I I
figured out eventually it was easier to
just go into the DMV and have them give
me a a driver's license than actually
make one so but you notice they would
just grab the thing they feel the form
and go okay like they don't even look at
it so which is upsetting if you put as
much work into these documents as I am
for them to go okay yeah that's good sit
over there I felt like going like hey
bro like take a look at this this is
artwork yeah but they're looking for the
loow hanging fruit of crappy fraud right
yeah this stuff was right through so
okay so so birth certificate gets you a
uh Social Security number so it's it's
it's interesting because you've also you
you've done a lot of different
approaches to um creating synthetic
people there's homeless people involved
so sometimes it's grounded in real
people or real
names and then you're right like some
part is fake some part is real sometimes
and sometimes it's completely all fake
right cuz now I have the name I have the
social security number and what's great
is they mail you what's even better is
you get then you get to pick whatever
name you want you know because when you
pick your child's name he doesn't even
have to have your last name you pick any
name so I would pick a name and just say
oh my wife's last name is this if it
they questioned it which they never did
but you know I've got a social security
number and then I would go apply for
credit cards and I'd get denied of
course but they would all offer me a
secured credit card so I I'd then fill
out the secured credit card and i' send
them send the bank the money and they
would give me a secured credit card for
$500 $300 1,000 whatever it was and then
once you start making the
payments I pulled the credit and a
credit cred profile shows up saying that
this 31y old man with a social security
number that I know was issued you know a
couple months ago has three three credit
cards they don't even say secure they
just say there's like this credit card
is $500 it was issued by Bank of America
this one was issued by Capital One this
one so I've got three of them but I had
no credit
scores so at that point I kind of kicked
back and waited and I just kept making
payments and I remember thinking to
myself
I'll bet you they don't that the credit
bureaus don't generate credit scores for
at least a year and I was like God this
is going to be a year-long process and
while that was happening I started other
I was starting other ones because I
figured at least in a year I'll have a
bunch of these secure you know these um
we call them like Phantom borrowers but
now they call them synthetic identities
so at least I would have these synthetic
identities and maybe I could do
something with them but what happened
was at six months I went and I randomly
pulled the guy's credit you know the
person's credit and
705 credit scores 705 701 695 I was like
oh my go you only needed a 620 to borrow
to get a 95% loan from the bank so I was
like oh my God this is in this is
amazing sure enough a month later the
other ones I had started all of them Bam
Bam Bam so what do you do with a phantom
borrower like what how do you make money
on this so I think most people if you
were just like a scammer a fraudster you
would you would probably just get credit
cards and maybe build up that history or
maybe try and borrow a personal loan uh
which is limited you know it's personal
loans are used to be you used to be you
could go
to uh an FDIC insured bank which borrows
money
those you know the personal loans they
lend out at the max $115,000 you know so
you could do that so you can go through
this whole process creating a fake
identity getting a card paying it off
building up credit and then you get
$15,000 at the end or right you get 15
maybe you know if you want to keep
making the payments you know if you
could wait a year you could probably get
15,000 uh maybe you could maybe get 20
30,000 and a bunch of little smaller
ones you know you get 7500 cuz I did I
did there was $7,500 from City Bank you
know $5,500 from American General so you
maybe get what 25,000 you know maybe
30,000 in personal loans maybe you can
you could you could then apply for you
maybe get another 20 or 30,000 in
regular credit cards you know 10,000
here 8,000 5,000 and then you go to the
lower department store cards and you go
to Home Depot you get a th000 you get
500 so it ends up being maybe you can
get 50 60,000 maybe if you really good
you could get up to 80 or $100,000 in
credit cards and personal loans if you
really knew what you were doing but per
person per identity per identity but I
had the ability
to to leverage that perfect those
perfect credit profiles against
properties and I mean ultimately that's
what I end up doing and and so each one
of those identities was
worth you know a few
million
that